Hi everyone, my name is Briana Frank and I'm with the IBM Cloud team. Let's talk about IBM Cloud Code Engine.
Today, many enterprises are benefiting from using public cloud toconsume IT as a service, through APIs, at scale.
Bringing faster innovation and flexibility, but let me ask you something. Are you able to shield your developers from
instrasturcure complexity, so they can simply focus on their code?
We see that in real live developers struggle with sizing, managing, securing and scaling for virtual machines
or Kubernetes clusters.
So we are taking "Serverless" to the next level with IBM Code Engine.
Now you can get a single deployment experience whether you are running containers, building and deploying source code
or submitting large batch workloads on the IBM Cloud.
All with a common API, user experience, management dashboard and "pay per use" consumption model.
To see how IBM Cloud Code Engine works, let’s take a look at a real-world example.
Airlines run on razor-thin margins and a key driver for profitability is accurate passenger forecasting
and dynamic pricing.
An airline is about to overhaul its pricing strategy by offering dynamic pricing based on daily demand.
This project architecture will consist of a highly dynamic website displaying up-to-date pricing, and a series of
long-running batch jobs to collect operational airline data and competitor pricing.
This data will be fed into a machine learning model, whose output will determine the dynamic pricing
that is displayed on the customer-facing website.
The airline loves the portability and openness of containers but does not want to invest in
learning complicated Kubernetes concepts.
Instead, they want a Serverless platform to just "push code to the cloud" and not have to worry about managing infrastructure.
Like everyone in IT, they have a tight budget and worry about over-provisioning costly infrastructure,
which makes the Code Engine "pay per use" model perfect for them.
Code Engine also uses a secure private network to handle both their CPU-intense batch jobs
along with their highly scalable web front-end on the same platform.
And lastly, it uses serverless management to scale workloads up or down, so they pay only for what they use.
The net result? Their IT team focus less on the infrastructure, and more on driving the business.
To learn more, go to the IBM Cloud Code Engine page,
or watch our other videos to see how to actually use IBM Cloud Code Engine.
Thanks for watching.
If you have questions, please drop us a line below.
If you want to see more videos like this in the future, please like and subscribe.